[Musik]
hey ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute wie
ihr ganz einfach und schnell fluffige
amerikanische pancakes hinbekommt wir
hatten jetzt krebs und pfannkuchen und
hab ich mir gedacht das trio muss
komplett sein
in dem wird einfach pancakes machen aber
ich zeige euch das ganze jetzt schritt
für schritt ich bin uns heute die
küchenmaschine
natürlich könnt ihr euer handrührgerät
benutzen dauerte nur ein paar minuten
länger beim aufschlagen und wichtig bei
pancakes ist dass wir jetzt die eier
getrennt voneinander verarbeiten also
erstmal das eiweiß in die rührschüssel
geben da kommt eine ordentliche prise
salz dazu dann schlage ich das so
ungefähr 30 sekunden damit so ein
bisschen schaumig und dick geht und dann
kommt der zucker dazu und wird zu einer
beigen asse geschlagen also komplett
steif geschlagen
[Musik]
so nach zwei minuten wenn ihr die eier
richtig schön sauber getrennt hat und
kein fertiges eigelb mehr in der
eismasse ist habt ihr eine richtig
schöne baiser masse moment wird kurz
laut so nichts mehr spenden
so sieht's aus die kommen ganz kurz zur
seite die darf nicht zu lange stehen
weil sie sonst einsingen deshalb machen
werden direkt weiter aber ich spüre
jetzt nicht diesen schneebesen nicht bar
mit diesem schritt gibt es die andere
regisseur drauf und dann r wird das
eigelb zusammen mit vanille extrakt auch
so 23 minuten richtig schön cremig
geschlagen und dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
so danach einmal buttermilch
hinzugegeben kurz verrühren lassen und
anschließend einmal die trockenen
zutaten vorab verrühren das heißt mehl
mit backpulver und natron verrühren und
zur masse 7 und das habe ich jetzt hier
schon erledigt so das will ich jetzt
auch noch mal ganz kurz mit ein und
falls ihr euch jetzt wundert wo sind
denn hier die ganz genauen mengenangaben
die findet ihr immer unter der video
unter dem video titel in der video
beschreibung und habt es nämlich ganz
genau so das rühre ich jetzt ganz kurz
mit ein und danach mit ganz viel liebe
die b&c masse unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans auspacken der tag ist
jetzt fertig habe die erfahrung gemacht
dass wenn er ungefähr zehn minuten ruht
das er dann einfach also dass die
pancakes dann perfekt werden nur so als
tipp nehmen weil ich nehme immer gerne
kokosfett zum ausbacken von pancakes
geschmacklich sind die dann einfach top
und ich habe auch das gefühl dass sie
von der oberfläche her einfach besser
werden
alternativen wären jetzt zum beispiel
raps oder sonnenblumenöl aber auf keinen
fall olivenöl oder sowas habe ich jetzt
die beschichtete pfanne mit eingefettet
und was ich noch machen damit sie
wirklich perfekt werden das auge ist
natürlich mit ich nehme mein mini
tortenring als alternative könnte jetzt
ein ausstecher nehmen am besten sollte
auch relativ hoch sein damit er nicht an
der oberfläche also damit er hier oben
nicht so heiß wie du ihn in ruhe
anfassen können einmal ein bisschen
einfetten mit kokosfett und jetzt damit
ihr auch immer gleich hoch nämlich mir
mein als portionierer geht da rein und
dann verteile ich das noch so ein
bisschen und backt die von beiden seiten
aus
[Musik]
so sind die nächsten zwei fertig und ich
packe jetzt hier einfach freudig vor
mich hin und das euch gehen ihr müsst
ihr herz ihnen waren sie sehen welche
schönen entsehen die der haben soll
macht und dann könnt ihr das mit
ahornsirup oder mit honig oder mit
nutella mit was auch immer ich möchte
könnt ihr das genießen was auch super
passt sind frische früchte aber ich
wollte euch vorher noch den tipp geben
natürlich müsst ihr selber gucken wie
lange das zum ausbacken braucht jeder
auch wieder offen jeder her ist anders
jeder fall ist anders aber mir war es so
ich habe neun stufen und ich schwanke
immer zwischen stufe vier und fünf also
mittlere hitze und dann brauch ist von
jeder seite so ungefähr drei bis maximal
vier minuten müsste einfach mal schauen
und dann gelingt euch das
hundertprozentig ich gebe euch die linke
garantie dass ihr fluffige pancakes ihm
bekommen werdet mit diesem rezept also
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen und ich
freue mich über eure fotos steckt mich
gerne auf instagram dann kann ich die
posten mir angucken und darüber freue
ich mich mal wirklich sehr und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten video und
abonnieren nicht vergessen
bis dann tschüss
[Musik]